John seduced me into writing a book a
lot of people a lot of publishers had
always said to me you should you know
put out a book of your interviews and I
know he's kind of toyed with the idea
but John showed up my apartment with
Vinny Pahlavi yes it was John Vinny Sean
man Oh Sean whoo yeah yeah that's how I
first met Sean yeah Sean who edited the
book uh-huh who's a great guy real
talented guy but what really freaked me
out is that book you're holding in your
hand what did you do you put together a
whole book how it used to earn the
interviews yes and it's 256 pages we
even have these nice and papers here
yeah look at that that's what they
handed me and you had been my white
whale I had been pursuing you for about
12 years
you didn't row it no you were talking my
agent Dunn I talked to Don Buckwald I
took him out to lunch I send him free
books I was doing everything I could you
could see how serious I was about not
writing 12 years you know eventually I
get seduced because they go out to be
really exciting to have a book but I got
to tell you now on publication date I
really am excited because to see all
those interviews and everything in one
compilation and people get and I'm
pretty excited about the whole thing
John well happy publication day Howard
it's been a great experience and has it
been a great experience because I feel
like it was difficult for you there was
one point where I was kind of you were
like let's publish the book already and
I had to kind of keep yelling I'm not
ready yet
you know the guys wanted to get the book
out right you felt you were being a big
problem to them I did I felt terrible
but you were having a hard time with
that too right you wanted a date a
publication date well you you did
something like seven drafts of this book
and I read draft three on draft three
was great was it it really was I'm not
saying like I did I was just like it I'm
not digging deep enough well that's why
you're that's why you're great and and
you were you were right to persist but
you know there's some really really I
mean Charles Dickens only took eight
months to do great expectations
you could have gotten it done and but I
can't dig ins didn't have a radio that's
true I wasn't working full-time during
this process of writing the book I kept
saying to John and his team I said you
know I'm really not doing this to be an
[ __ ] but I just know that if
something good at least something I'm
proud of I've got to keep making
revisions if I need to but yeah I mean
I'm doing a ton of promotion for this
book cuz I really am proud of it so you
know you were you were right to sign me
up and push me to do this I thank you